evening we are tracking a developing
situation near the south
end of the strip where metro police are
investigating a homicide thanks for
joining us at six i'm denise valdez and
i'm brian loftis investigators say a
woman was found dead near
koval and tropicana orcomanna joining us
live
right near the scene with the very
latest of developments
brian and denise metro police tell us
that woman was found here
at this motel off tropicana and koval
right off the las vegas strip
detectives have been out here for a few
hours now and they are calling this a
very dynamic scene
now just about an hour and a half ago we
did see metro
take a few people into custody but right
now it's still not 100 percent clear
who those people are we do know that
metro had been
trying to locate the suspect in this
homicide since they first arrived on
scene here which was about
three o'clock this afternoon again all
of this has been unfolding
within just the last couple of hours
here and we are hoping to learn more
details from metro police
about what exactly happened here so we
again are awaiting a briefing from
police
in about the next hour or so so be sure
to stay with 8 news now
for the latest developments for now
reporting live near the las vegas strip
tonight orco mana
8 news now